I'm the luckiest woman in America I hope
all the girls that were mean to me in
high school are watching this right now
Mark Consuelos and Kelly Ripa may be
couple goals now he has to realize that
I'm the queen and I'm the king so
there's the balance of power
definitely shifts back and forth but
they weren't always so secure in their
relationship to us and they said it
wouldn't I said it wouldn't last in a
new excerpt from Phil Donahue and Marlo
Thomas's book what makes a marriage last
obtained by people mark opens up about
his jealous streak at the start of his
now 24 year marriage to Kelly we had we
were friends for a long time I mean
before anything yeah before we crossed
the line a good we were friends for at
least a week before anything way before
anything happened
mark explains that after they were
married he was doing a show in Boston
and he couldn't get ahold of Kelly all
day which he said gave him a really bad
feeling so he hopped on a flight to New
York and called her from the plane to
ask what she was doing that night when
Kelly said she would be cleaning toilets
he wasn't buying it Kelly explains quote
apparently he thought that sounded very
fishy he wanted to catch me Kelly said
her hubby told the doorman to call up to
the apartment and tell her there was a
flower delivery for her I'm excited
because I'm thinking oh my gosh he's
sending me flowers meanwhile I have a
Johnny mop in one hand and I'm wearing a
bathrobe that's when Kelly opened the
door and Mark stormed in like a bat out
of hell
he doesn't even say hello he's looking
for something I'm still looking for the
flower guy and he is sweeping the scene
mark added that the jealousy feels
horrible and you know you're wrong I'm
less jealous these days the two met in
1995 during a screen test for all my
children mark was just 23 years old and
was auditioning for the role Kelly was
already a member of the cast and was
assigned to screen tests with him she
was like helping me rehearse for the
screen test the next day and she
answered the door in her robe I knew
then I knew then it was
it was it was meant to be um does it get
any cuter than that apparently it does
because they both agree it was love at
first sight
I don't remember yesterday but I
remember I remember everything about the
day I met him
I always head over heels before we even
actually worked together on understand a
classic Hollywood romance lovers on
screen and off they are Halley and
Matteo all my children's favorite couple
we were practicing for years we look at
what yeah so that was 1995 and by 1996
wedding bells were ringing and then you
begged me to marry you right a few short
months later yeah about a year later but
like me to marry you and then we went to
Las Vegas and got married and didn't
tell anybody for a few months and then
we found out we were pregnant three kids
and almost 25 years later Kelly and Marc
are still going strong and despite any
staged flower deliveries back in the day
they're absolutely our definition of
couple goals I would say marriage is a
blessing
I've had a great time being married
[Music]